Johnny wrote in John, he says, David WTF is
Nancy Polosi doing, she can't be playing politics
if she is, America is losing also.
Is it possible that this anti impeachment
stuff from Pelosi is a strategy?
I genuinely don't know.
Um, my, my instinct is that Nancy Pelosi just
doesn't think that trying to impeach Trump
is a good idea.
I think that that's genuinely her belief.
Let me, I think that she's wrong.
I think that the Democratic Party would benefit
significantly from immediately starting an
impeachment inquiry into Donald Trump getting
the content of the Mueller report out in front
of the House of Representatives, informing
the American people who mostly have not read
the molar report, informing some of the Fox
News audience, piercing the Echo Chamber of
some of the Fox News audience so that they
realize that William bars, no collusion, no
obstruction, uh, nonsense is simply nonsense
and not actually found anywhere in the actual
Mueller report.
I think that would be really good.
So if Nancy Polosi genuinely believes that
impeachment inquiries in the house would not
be a good idea or would not be a good strategy,
I simply disagree with her.
However, if you said to me, David, is there
any way in which Nancy Pelosi might be executing
some kind of really great strategy around
the idea of not impeaching Donald Trump not
starting an impeachment inquiry.
Now the best, the steel manning, the best
possible steel manning I can do of Nancy Pelosi's
position is that she has calculated that it's
too early to launch an impeachment inquiry
and that it would be more damaging to Trump
to do it in a few months, in six months or
something like that.
In terms of the 2020 election, would she be
right?
If that was her perspective?
I don't know.
Um, I, I actually think that there would be
a strong cumulative effect of starting the
impeachment inquiry now, I think an impeachment
inquiry that starts now and exposes a lot
of really damaging possibly criminal activity
by Donald Trump, which is what is in the Mueller
report.
Remember, might entice more republicans to
join the primary and run against Trump in
addition to just former Libertarian William
Weld, who now is running as a Republican challenger
to Donald Trump.
If you bring in more strong Republican challengers
to Donald Trump, it will cause Donald Trump
to have to expend resources and political
capital.
And there will be media time devoted to the
fact that Republicans are challenging Trump
that will damage Donald Trump in a way that
could be really good for Democrats.
So I don't think that Nancy Pelosi has some
broader strategy of delaying impeachment inquiries
until such time that they're more damaging
to Donald Trump.
I also disagree that weighting would be more
damaging to Donald Trump impeachment inquiries.
And impeachment in general is a big, slow,
uh, muddied up process that can take a long
time and it has many parts and I think that
there would not be an advantage to waiting.
So if that's what she's doing, I disagree
with her, but I genuinely think that Nancy
Pelosi just doesn't think that impeachment
inquiries or actual articles of impeachment
are a good idea.
I have no reason to think that she's playing
coy or trying to affect some broader strategy